joining me now Tulsa gabbard former
Hawaii congresswoman Fox News
contributor and another former Democrat
Tulsi great to see you tonight now I
think what most of the of today's
Democratic party they haven't grappled
with the fact that people aren't leaving
the party because of just one issue
they're leaving the party because of
like 10 issues uh in the Lurch to the
left that's I mean they've they've gone
so far left they've left America I mean
this is an unrecognizable Coalition of
radicals
yeah Laura they're they're lurching
farther and farther towards Insanity
really there's no other word that I can
find to describe it you know the the the
list of reasons unfortunately is long
and I think we will continue to see more
and more Americans who maybe call
themselves Democrats and or or used to
but but leaving the Democratic party
because of a whole host of reasons it's
it's you know an elitist cabal of War
mongers it's made of politicians the
propaganda media big Tech and the
National Security State they are
weaponizing the security state to go
after political opponents they're
undermining our god-given rights and
freedoms enshrined in the Constitution
uh you know they're they are seeking to
censor and silence anyone who does not
agree with them they're tearing us apart
with identity politics and racializing
everything looking at what the NAACP
just announced with Florida I mean the
the list unfortunately we could do a
whole show on all of these things and
and I think more and more Americans are
seeing clearly uh what they're doing not
not to the party this isn't about the
party but it's really what are they
doing to this country and how are they
undermining our rights and freedoms in
our democracy that that's really what's
at the heart of this well you think of
um someone like an FDR or a JFK let's go
back to two classic figures that
Democrats claim to Revere I mean you go
back and look at their you know
inaugural addresses they were so
optimistic they embraced America the
tradition of America the patriotism uh
you know the you know our meaning as a
country what did our country actually
mean what is freedom all about
that is God they would be I mean rolling
over in the grave is such a cliche Tulsi
I mean they'd be like doing a triple
Luts okay watching this Democrat party
today and now the new Democratic style
yeah they're pro-war as well you touched
on that yeah
and and that's you mentioned JFK I went
back and reread his speech that he
delivered at American University
specifically warning those students in
the American people about the risk of
nuclear war and speaking in a hopeful uh
tone saying that even though it may seem
impossible that this danger just seems
too great there is a way and we must
continue to pursue that path towards
peace you you listen to his message
which is so inspiring and so truthful
and so relevant today and you look at
people like President Biden and other
leaders of the democratic party they're
talking about they have pushed us to the
brink of nuclear war and they're talking
about nuclear war with a straight face
as though it's just some other war that
we have to fight and we have to win
without being honest to the American
people that a nuclear war would destroy
Life as We Know It And would would
destroy this planet that we live on so
you know they're being dishonest and in
their dishonesty creating a greater
threat to our safety security and
freedom and it just shows that this
elitist party cares about themselves
their own power maintaining and growing
that power and they don't care they
don't care about the American people I
want to get your reaction Tulsi to the
headline that touches on one weird new
obsession of the left black magas make
America great again um adherence are a
clear and present danger lacking
principles black white nationalists say
and do anything to please Trump trumpism
and the white supremacist base as the
colorized and melanated enablers of
fascism today's black magas are truly
dangerous jokes okay there was the super
mega Maga and as there's the black mag
of threat super threat they're running
out of yeah hispanic white nationalist
Tommy just reminded me of the list goes
on and on they've called they've called
me they've called me a sexist a
misogynist a white supremist like they
just throw all these names out there
congrats and it doesn't make sense Tulsi
great to see you tonight thanks so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else